(children talking)
- Victor, I love your ability to admit
that you wanna do better at times,
and then how committed
you are to doing that.
Circles are a time for the
community to come together
and develop themselves as individuals,
develop their relationships,
and really address community work.
And we actually believe
that by doing that,
kids will succeed more academically
because they feel safe and they're
in trusting relationships.
- Thanks.
- Valor is a middle school
based in Nashville, Tennessee.
We really value our
relationships with each other,
and we work really hard to create
the school community that
we want to be a part of.
Circle is an important part of that work.
(man speaking)
- Our circle model is something that both
our adults and our scholars
do every week for an hour.
Is there more you need to talk about?
- Circle happens in single-gender groups
of about 20 or so students
led by their mentor teacher.
- That's really impressive.
Circle is done in a structured manner.
It's very different than
the classroom experience
that they have at other
points during the day,
kind of invites them to be exploring
and learning in a different way.
Every circle will follow
the same basic cadence.
- All right.
We're gonna start by doing our True North.
- It'll always start with what
we call True North Practice.
- Start by taking one
silent, deep breath in,
and then slowly letting it out.
- It's a mindfulness-based practice
for everybody in the circle
to let go of the busy day
and really focus their
attention on each other.
- We are going to do a weather check-in.
Who would like to start us off?
- And then it moves into a check-in.
- Today, I'm feeling
foggy because I'm sleepy.
- Everybody has to check
in, even if it's minimal.
- I feel sunny because it's Friday.
- Being able to name their emotions,
I think it humanizes everybody involved.
It really helps us see each other
as people who have feelings.
- And then we move into what we call work.
- Outside of the classroom and not...
- I was a little bit frustrated.
- So this is the biggest step
of the whole relationship work.
You need to let Jerron
know that you understand
why he felt frustrated, okay?
Communities need to work together
in order to solve problems, and so
people have the opportunity
to bring work into circle.
- Examples of work are relationship work
with your peers or with your teacher.
We might have people take responsibility
for something that had an
impact on our community.
We also do activities like
sharing your life story,
reflecting on your values.
- Sawyer, are you ready
to do your presentation?
- The topic I investigated was religion.
- Scholars really push themselves
and put a lot of effort
and thought into the work.
You see them starting to become
more thoughtful about
themselves, more self-aware.
- This experience helped me
learn that I can be kinder
to people with different perspectives.
- Then we always end with appreciations.
- You always make me laugh.
- You always kept trying to get better.
- It's a way for the
community to appreciate
the positive impacts
we have on each other.
- I like to appreciate you for talking
to me over spring break.
It's like a mini family.
It's a place where you know you're safe.
I don't talk about my feelings much,
but in circle, I can
because I know I can trust them.
- I think having the adults
do the practice themselves
and really know the importance
of it is our main strategy.
- In through your nose,
and out through your mouth.
Allow your breath to anchor you.
- Adults drive this type
of work in the community.
- Steven, would you mind kicking assess?
- There's some work
that I've done with kids
in this past week that I
need to bring to circle.
In circle today, I did a process called
taking responsibility, which is used for
repairing a relationship with
the community as a whole.
You step into the circle and you own
whatever action you took.
I recognize that my mistake put you
in a really uncomfortable position.
I have been at schools
where if something were done
and not talked about, it kinda festered.
Here, you positively work
to rebuild the relationship.
Moving forward, I commit to using
the systems that are in place
and thinking before I act in such a way.
I ask kids to do it every day,
and I think that's why Valor works
is because everything
the kids are asked to do,
the adults are expected to do as well.
- It helps a lot because they also know
what we're going through.
Other schools can say, "You
don't understand your teachers,"
but we can't say that because
they do the same thing as us,
and they know what we're going through.
- Circle is a space that's safe enough
that we can share and
it can be vulnerable.
It also builds relationships
that help us become
better teachers, help them
become better learners.
- You guys did a really good job.
Appreciate yourselves for that.